all right let's move on to the to the
other big story of the week uh we're not
going to do too much on the war itself
although you guys can feel free to bring
up whatever you want obviously but let's
just talk about the energy situation at
home and gas prices let's throw this
image up from cbs la this is the city
that i fled that mobile station was on
the corner of uh
not the last house i lived in the
previous one the gas prices are
completely
insane
735
for regular unleaded gas really nuts but
don't worry guys we've got jen saki on
the case here's this little video that
she put out to calm us down
you may have noticed this week that your
gas prices have gone up i want to talk
to you a little bit about why a lot of
it has to do with vladimir putin
[Music]
the reality is that russia is one of the
three largest oil producers in the world
and the fact that they have started this
conflict invaded a foreign country and
they are such a big producer of oil in
the world is the reason why the global
oil markets are disturbed right now and
why your gas prices are going up and so
to that point inflation goes up today
the president's statement blames the
putin price hike are you guys just going
to start blaming putin for everything
until the midterms well we've seen the
price of gas go up at least 75 cents
since president putin lined up troops on
the border of ukraine last month the
statement didn't mention the putin price
hike it mentioned inflation because of
the pandemic why is that
well peter last year last two years
there was a global pandemic everyone
who's a global economist have all agreed
that that has been the biggest
contributor to date of inflation because
of the impact on the supply chain
obviously global events impact the
economy the global economy as well as
global inflation and the uh price hikes
as a result that have
escalated over the course of time of
president putin's further invasion of uh
the impact on the global oil markets are
of course having an impact
oh solis
just lying and lying and lying about
everything uh my guys did a little
research here we've got researchers too
gas
from the day that joe biden took uh
office so the day that he was
inaugurated until the day that putin uh
went into ukraine went up a dollar 14.
so yes it's gone up since but it was
going up the entire time
kyle was there something
help me here was there something that
joe biden did right when he got into
office that might have uh did he stop
something that might have helped with
this situation well there's something i
keep i had papers here
was there something i think there was
something well i think he pretty much
gave us all a warning when the first
thing he did was jump onto the paris
accords and adopted this this crazy uh
you know uh carbon zero strategy which
is basically about as futile as the uh
it's coveted zero strategy that we've
seen you know attempted to be
implemented around the world uh we saw
it with the federal leases uh situation
is pretty interesting a lot of drillers
are complaining they can't get the
capital lending that they need in order
to do this drilling there are some
bottlenecks in the regulatory framework
that he's imposed and of course the
keystone xl a pipeline which is
bottlenecked the transit that to get to
the refineries that are on the gulf
coast that allow us to you know refine
our own gasoline which helps bring
prices down uh on the margins but i
think overall jen is just you know being
her own usual devilish self and sort of
creating this sort of cloud in people's
minds but the fact is that you know like
you saw at the hollywood sign it's now
higher than the gasoline was in the
apocalyptic film i am legend with will
smith it was only 671 a gallon there so
i think biden's pregnancy is making us
pine to live in dystopian fiction at
this point uh and that's pretty much
fiction is all that gensake has to pedal
at this point it's not putting food on
the table it's not putting gasoline in
our tanks so it's pretty much uh empty
gruel to to dish out to the plebes uh
that she's offered this point i think
that normal people are tuning her out
it's not going to fly at the dinner
table and it's not going to fly in the
upcoming elections
that is a great reference man did they
show you the the prices right at the
beginning when they show you that sort
of dystopia in new york city they have
like an image of it is that where you're
grabbing that from yeah yeah 671 in the
clip you can you can find it there's
like a little meme thing floating around
you can find it i i will take your word
on that um ian
is there anything we could be doing to
helping right now is there anything that
biden's not doing that might help i
think uh kyle might have alluded to
something
yeah i think the only thing we can do is
start getting some republicans in office
honestly i mean
biden has been a disaster both on the
foreign policy front but also the energy
front since he came in talked about the
paris climate of course talked about
closing the keystone xl pipeline but on
a higher level every single one of his
solutions involves green energy which
europe has showed is not a solution the
solution is under us right now is the
fact that the united states as of 2016
is sitting on the most untapped oil in
the world we have the solution beneath
our feet but people like biden are too
busy sucking up to the green energy
crowd to really acknowledge that and i
think in some ways the war between
russia and ukraine with russia invading
ukraine is somewhat of a blessing for
biden economically because now with
covid not an excuse anymore cobit is
over and has been over for a while they
have another excuse because the price
has
been increasing month on month since he
came into office inflation is at record
rates and so this is just a very very
public thing that biden can point to and
blame and of course when it comes down
eventually if he's still in office he'll
take credit for that he's very very good
at taking credit for good things whether
he's responsible or not and blaming
others and so the fact that it's a putin
price hike is absurd also demonstrative
of the earlier issue where the media has
embraced this messaging that it's the
putin pride hike which of course it's
not right putin price hike that's the
meme just like don't say gay became the
meme they just manufacture these things
that are not true and then everyone just
repeats and repeats it sarah could you
allow me to
toss up a conspiracy theory here and you
tell me
completely insane i know you work with
that steve diese over there who's always
throwing out those crazy wild conspiracy
theories over at the blaze like you know
this great reset or some of these things
but my feeling is these people could not
possibly be this inept i don't think
they could be this inept and my belief
is actually that everything that the two
guys here just laid out about keystone
and not giving permits and all this
stuff is intentional that they are
two-fold i would say trying to
upend the world energy system and
basically destroy america like i i
actually honestly believe that at this
point am i completely crazy will i be
booted free from youtube for saying that
no well i mean i can't speak for youtube
but uh i mean i can tell you that all of
the evidence points to that right
because you have them making these epic
levels of propaganda government
propaganda videos trying to have the
white house press secretary who is a
professional liar come in and explain to
people why it is that gas prices are
rising when people i mean
i understand some americans are a little
i would say uh disconnected from reality
but i don't think that americans have
that short of a memory that they don't
realize that before all of this was
going on two months ago three months ago
they were paying more at the pump they
were paying more at the grocery store
they're paying more for everything i
don't think that they have such short
attention spans that they don't remember
that but more importantly
we heard joe biden in the last
presidential debate say that he was
going to transition from the oil and gas
sector from the oil and gas industry he
said it and remember we all all the
republicans sat there and watched it and
went oh my gosh he said the quiet part
out loud there's no way he gets past
that he has to be toast
and then as we know how it turned out he
is the most popular president of all
time 81 million votes uh the most secure
election that we've ever had but he was
saying these things he was telling us
that he was going to do these things
it's a wonder to me that he doesn't want
to take the credit because as kamal
harris said uh you know you get what you
vote for
meaning uh we're doing all of these
things that we said we were going to do
and he is so i think you're right dave i
think the answers were right in front of
us they told us what they were going to
do now that they're doing it uh they
don't like the the criticism they don't
like the the uh the the pain that
americans are feeling not because they
care about americans but because they
know it makes them look bad and they
want to continue their power
crazy conspiracy theory indeed put the
tinfoil hat right on me